Hallo und herzlich Willkommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast von ESA und DLR. Mein Name ist Tim Fritlaff und ich begrüße alle zu einer weiteren und einer ganz besonderen Ausgabe in dieser Serie von Gesprächen mit Leuten, die ja in der Organisation, in der Technik, der Raumfahrt drinstecken. Und der eigentliche Anlass für die heutige Ausgabe ist ein Jubiläum. Das ist schlicht und ergreifend der 50. Geburtstag der bemannten Raumfahrt, wenn man ausgeht von dem Datum, wo der erste Mensch in den Orbit aufgestiegen ist, Juri Gagarin. Und ja, anlässlich dieses Ereignisses haben wir uns entschlossen, mal einen Blick in die Vergangenheit, aber in gewisser Hinsicht dann auch wieder in die Gegenwart zu richten. Und ich freue mich auf den idealen Gesprächspartner für dieses Thema, nämlich Sigmund Jähn. Schönen guten Tag. Ja, zu Ihnen muss man ja eigentlich gar nicht so viel sagen. Zumindest ist schon viel geschrieben und berichtet worden. Kurz gesagt, Sie waren von Anfang an dabei und Teil dieser gesamten Bewegung. Letztlich der erste Deutsche, der an dieser Raumfahrt teil gehabt hat. Was einem sicherlich auch in eine merkwürdige Situation bringt, manchmal, wenn alle Augen so auf einen gerichtet sind. Aber ich glaube, für Sie war das immer eine ganz normale Tätigkeit in gewisser Hinsicht, oder?
Da müsste ich erzählen, wie ich in die Raumfahrt gekommen bin. Das lief ja in der DDR und nicht nur in der DDR, insgesamt in den damaligen sozialistischen Ländern alles ein bisschen anders. Es gab also keine öffentliche Ausschreibung, man konnte sich nicht melden. Aber es gab im Sommer des Jahres 1976 offenbar einen Beschluss der sowjetischen Regierung, das Interkosmos-Programm, das könnte ich etwa mit der ESA vergleichen, aber nur in etwa, es war also nur ein Programm, keine Organisation. Das Interkosmos-Programm, wo z.B. die DDR mit Geräteentwicklungen teilgenommen hatte, gegründet wurde, ist dieses Programm in den 60er Jahren, wenn ich mich nicht irre, um 65 rum. Die DDR war sehr aktiv mit Geräteentwicklungen, mit Spektrometern, es gab Raketen, die geschossen wurden, regelrechte Interkosmos-Raketen, so wurden sie bezeichnet. Und dann wurde beschlossen, in Moskau doch Kandidaten für bemannte Raumfliege hinzuzuziehen. Die Leute sollten einen wissenschaftlichen Hintergrund haben, sie sollten Russisch sprechen, wirklich ordentlich, sie sollten hundertprozentig flugtauglich sein, Erfahrungen haben mit Strahlflugzeugen. Also kurz gesagt, sie haben dann gesagt, ideal wären Jagdflieger, weil man auch den Gesundheitszustand kennt. Und so ist die Auswahl gelaufen in dem Kreis der Jagdflieger, nicht nur in der DDR, sondern parallel in der Tschechoslowakischen Republik damals, in Polen. Und aus diesen drei Ländern sollten dann Kandidaten letzten Endes ausgewählt werden, jeweils zwei. Es beschränkte sich also auf einen relativ engen Kreis. Wir hatten, grob gesagt, 800 Jagdflieger, die in Frage kamen, oder vielleicht insgesamt Flieger. Es wurden auf dem Papier so um die 20 vielleicht ein bisschen mehr Leute ausgewählt. Und dann gab es eine neue Geschichte. Ich wurde früh von meinem Chef, ich war also in der Volksarmee, natürlich Jagdflieger und arbeitete als Inspekteur für Jagdflieger-Ausbildung und für Flugsicherheit. Und mein Chef sagte früh, du sollst zum Chef kommen, also zum ganz großen Chef. Da ist irgendetwas, nur wenn einer nicht genau weiß, warum sein Untergeber zum ganz großen Chef kommen soll, hat er Fragen natürlich. Ich hatte auch Fragen gegen so eine Belobigung, hast du irgendwas verpockt oder so. Naja, im Vorzimmer trafen sich da so 15, 16 Mann, ich weiß nicht mehr ganz genau. Keiner wusste, worum es ging. Und jeder wurde einzeln dann reingerufen in dem Raum, war ein Vertreter oder ganz konkret der Chef der Akademie der Wissenschaften der DDR, verantwortlich für Raumfahrt. Also von diesem Rat Interkosmos nannte sich das, wurde Vorsitzende des Rates Interkosmos. Interkosmos, Zusammenarbeit mit Moskau. Und die Leute wurden nachher noch reingerufen. Keiner sagte was, als wir durch diesen Vorsaal durchgingen. Es war auch noch irgendwas geheim. Und wir rätselten auch, die da noch saßen. Es hätte ja auch eine militärische Aufgabe sein können, irgendwo hin gab es ja auch solche Geschichten. Und einer zeigte dann, der ausgerannten. Wir kannten uns gut mit dem Finger so nach oben. Dann waren wir klar, wohin der Schuss ging. Als ich dann gefragt wurde, ob ich da bereit wäre dazu, es ging um moderne Technik, ich könnte mir das zwei Tage überlegen, ob ich mitmachen will bei dem weiteren Auswahlverfahren, habe ich gesagt, natürlich. Sie können Ihre Frau fragen. Ich sagte, meine Frau brauche ich nicht fragen. Entweder sie sagt ja, was sie machen wird, oder sie sagt nein, dann lage ich trotzdem ja. Na ja, und dann ging das also weiter.
Also war es schon klar, dass es um Raumfahrt ging?
Dann wurde es klar. Dann wurde gesagt, es geht um Teilnahme an einem Raumfahrtprogramm, das die Sowjetunion sich dazu entschlossen hat, diesen Kreis ihrer eigenen Leute zu erweitern auf Ausländer aus den sozialistischen Staaten.
War das überraschend für Sie?
Na ja, es war in diesem Moment natürlich überraschend. Aber ich kann mich erinnern, ich hatte eine Militärakademie besucht in der Sowjetunion, daher auch natürlich die russischen Voraussetzungen. Und da hatten wir einen Kurs über bemannte Raumfahrt im Wesentlichen, mehr als militärischer Sicht. Und einer dieser Lektoren, auch ein Militär, der sagte dann irgendwo am Schluss, ich würde mich nicht wundern, wenn mal einer von euch hier wieder auftaucht, nicht auf der Militärakademie, sondern dieses Kosmonauten-Ausbildungszentrum befand sich nunmittelbarer Nähe etwas ab von Moskau und eine Raumfahrtausbildung durchläuft. Möglicherweise gab es da schon Gedanken. Naja, und dann ging die Auswahl weiter. Dann waren noch zehn Mann übrig geblieben etwa. Es wechselte auch mal einer mehr, einer weniger von diesem großen Kreis. Dann blieben vier Mann übrig, nachdem schon eine sowjetische Delegation die Leute sich angeguckt hatte und auch Empfehlungen zur Auswahl gegeben hatte. Da werde ich bald rausgeflogen. Da hat mich einer von diesen Spezialisten gerettet. Ich hatte nämlich Schwierigkeiten, irgendwas zu riechen. Die forderten unter anderem bei diesen medizinischen Untersuchungen, die dann begonnen hatten, die Geruchstauglichkeit zu prüfen. Der HNO-Spezialist von uns hatte offenbar aus der Küche seiner Frau alle möglichen Substanzen zusammengekramt. Und ich sollte da riechen. Ich sage, es riecht nach irgendwas, aber ich kann nicht sagen, was es ist. Ich habe mit Küchengeschichten wenig zu tun. Das nächste Fleschlein das Gleiche. Er versorgte schon das Gesicht. Da kam dieser Mann aus Moskau mit einem Dolmetscher. Er hatte sich auch ein paar Fleschleine. Er fällte dem das, was da vor sich ging mit mir. Und dann nahm er auch so ein Fleschlein. Er hatte mehrere erst mal und dann eines gab er mir und sagte, was ist da drin, was ist? Ich sagte, Uxus, Essig. Ein scharfer Geruch, das kann man nicht verfehlen. Ich konnte ja auch riechen, aber ich wusste nicht, was das Rosmarin oder was für ein Zeug da alles ist. Na dann war ich dann gerettet und dann waren vier Mann durchgeblieben und mit vier Leuten fuhren wir nach Moskau. Da war dann auch eine Gruppe aus der Tschechoslowakei und aus Polen dabei.
Also jetzt nur vier aus Deutschland?
Vier aus Deutschland, ja. Und dann blieben zwei übrig und hatten nochmal die sowjetischen Experten die Sache begutachtet. Und es wurde dann empfohlen. Aber so eine Empfehlung kann man natürlich nicht umgehen. Wer von den vier Mannn bleiben sollte, von der sowjetischen Seite? Nur dann blieben zwei meine übrig.
Das waren sie.
Und guter Bekannter bis heute war Kölner. Es gab da ein Scherz, Kölner konnte nicht fliegen, weil er dann aus dem Westen gekommen wäre. Das war eigentlich nur ein Scherz. Bis heute muss man es gut vertragen. Das war nicht immer der Fall. Da sind natürlich auch Konkurrenzen da, was sich da nach der Ausbildung zeigte.
Was war denn der Grund überhaupt, dass die Russen jetzt auch außerhalb von Russland nach Astronauten oder Kosmonauten gesucht haben?
Da kann man verschiedene Gründe suchen. Ich kenne keine offiziellen. Auf jeden Fall lag ihnen schon daran, die wissenschaftlichen Potenzen zu bündeln. Also wir hatten in der DDR, würde ich schon denken, mit den besten Voraussetzungen. Wir hatten Carl Zeiss Jena. Es gab diese Multispektralkamera damals, die schon getestet worden war von sowjetischen Kosmonauten im Interkosmos-Programm.
Für die Erdbeobachtung?
Für die Erdbeobachtung. Und die war dann schon angedacht als stationäres Gerät für die neu zu bauende Raumstation. Das ging um Salut 6. Die Russen haben einen anderen Weg eingeschlagen als die Amerikaner ab einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt. Die Amerikaner hatten ja nach dem Apollo-Programm, nach dem Mond-Programm, auch eine Raumstation, Skylab. Und das war etwa zum gleichen Zeitpunkt, als die Russen auch eine Raumstation hatten, Salut 1. Die Russen haben aber fortgesetzt mit diesen Raumstationen. Salut 2, die ist kaputtgegangen, die hat nicht funktioniert. 3, 4, 5 und 6 war dann schon in der Konstruktion. Die Fachleute werden wissen, dass 3 und 5 unter einer anderen Gede gestanden, das waren also militärische Stationen, auch ein anderes Konstruktionsbüro. Aber es war immer so, dass nur ein Raumschiff ankoppeln konnte. Damit war natürlich die Flugdauer begrenzt durch die Ressourcen.
Weil es keine Versorgung gab?
Keine Versorgung, keinen Nachschub. Die Amerikaner hatten immerhin mit Skylab drei Besatzungen. Und Skylab war, könnte man schon sagen, moderner als auf jeden Fall Salut 1. Das war eine tolle Station. Ich kenne auch sowjetische Spezialisten, die das alles miterlebt haben, die die gesehen haben. Die war tipptopp groß. Mit dieser Saturn 5 P-Ragette, die übrig geblieben war, von dem Apollo-Programm und dem Mond-Programm. Eine sehr starke 3-Ragette. Damit konnte man eine große Masse draufsetzen. Das war bei den Russen noch nicht der Fall damals. Bis heute ist das auch normal. Aber 20 Tonnen ist eine bestimmte Begrenzung, was die Protonen-Ragette der Russen tragen kann. Also könnte man auch denken, sie hatten eine gute Strategie. Sie wollten eine Station schaffen, die zwei Docking-Ports hatte.
Also einen für die Raumfahrer und einen für die Versorgung?
Für die Versorgung oder zwei Raumschiffe, zwei Bebanderaumschiffe. Das war die Strategie. Wir nehmen die, wie sie manchmal sagten, scherbt die Demokraten mit auf und machen eine Stammbesatzung und eine Besuchsbesatzung oder eine internationale Besatzung, die dann rögelmäßig anfliegen können und gemeinsam Experimente machen können. Das heißt also, die Russen hatten zum Beispiel bei der konkreten Salut 6-Station den ersten Flug geplant drei Monate. Das war dann schon bei uns 140 Tage, dann 180 Tage. Da blieb es im Wesentlichen 180, ein halbes Jahr. Und dann mal später sogar ein Arzt, der ist auf über 300, 14 Monate, glaube ich, geflogen.
Enorme Zeiten auf jeden Fall.
Enorme Zeiten, ja, am Stück. Das war dann schon bei der Salut 7.
Das heißt, Salut 6 war dann ihre Raumstation?
Salut 6 war unsere Raumstation. Das könnte also der zweite Grund gewesen sein. Man könnte auch, die fragten danach, warum man uns überhaupt mitgenommen hat. Ich denke schon, dass das die Raumfahrt-Möglichkeiten in der DDR gerade noch stimuliert hat. Man kann aber auch denken, dass die Russen schon wussten, Shuttle entstand zu dieser Zeit. Shuttle kam noch nicht recht vorwärts mit diesen fliegenden Kacheln, mit diesen Wärmeschutz-Kacheln.
Dass man sich da sagte, wir müssen sozusagen das Maximum rausholen.
Ja, und es ist ja auch ein Politikum dabei gewesen, was in Deutschland sich besonders auch widerspiegelte. Ich meine, ich bin da völlig unschuldig, aber für die DDR war das schon ein Plus, sagen zu können, wir haben den ersten Raumflieger. Wenn das die Russen im Blick hatten, dass sie also vor den Amerikanern auch internationale Gäste mitnehmen, dann könnte es ein Grund gewesen sein.
Welchen Zustand hatte denn die Raumfahrtforschung in der DDR zu dem Zeitpunkt? Also es wurde schon zugearbeitet zum russischen Programm, aber inwiefern war denn die Raumfahrt dann auch schon immer verwurzelt? Wurde das von Anfang an in der DDR mit Priorität betrieben? Oder lag es erstmal eine Weile brach und irgendwann kam dann drauf, dass das doch mal eine tolle Sache wäre?
Na wie gesagt, es gab den Zusammenschluss in diesem Rad-Interkosmos. Die Russen wollten natürlich die Kapazitäten der sozialen Länder bündeln. In der DDR wurde im Rahmen der Akademie der Wissenschaften ein eigenes Institut gegründet. Das nannte sich zu Anfang Institut für Elektronik. Da war die Raumfahrt vielleicht noch nicht öffentlichkeitswirksam. Das gleiche Institut wurde später umgenannt Institut für Weltraumforschung, was auch dem Gagarin sprach. Natürlich mit Möglichkeiten, auch in die Industrie zu gehen. Zeiss war immer das Kombinat, was am meisten bringen konnte, wenn man was Neues bauen wollte oder zu Geräteentwicklungen in irgendwelche Teile brauchte. Ich war zu dieser Zeit noch nicht integriert. Ich habe das später kennengelernt. Eigentlich nach meinem Flug. Während der Flugvorbereitung kamen Spezialisten von diesem Institut und brachten uns die Experimentiereinrichtungen und haben uns auch eingewiesen.
Das heißt, der wissenschaftliche Nutzen der Raumfahrt war zu dem Zeitpunkt auch schon ein Mittelpunkt? Weil es ja auch eine Phase des militärischen Experimentierens gegeben hat, gerade mit den ersten Salut-Raumstationen. Was wurde dort probiert und warum wurde das nicht weiter betrieben?
Na ja, dort hat man uns nicht integriert in die militärischen Nutzungsmöglichkeiten. Wie gesagt, es gab die Raumstation Salut 1. Dort ist eine Besatzung geflogen. Das kann ich mir jetzt um ein paar Tage vertun. Ein paar zwanzig Tage. Die ist leider dann auch bei der Landung abgestürzt und ist zu Tode gekommen. Zwei haben sie nicht zum Arbeiten gebracht. Drei war schon eine militärische Station. Wie gesagt, ein anderes Konstruktionsbüro. Da hatten wir keinen Zugang. Das war auch damals noch völlig geheim. Vier, eine Station auch in der Sweden, von der Akademie der Wissenschaften oder als Eigentümer von der Akademie der Wissenschaften. Natürlich mag da das eine oder andere Experiment auch im militärischen Sinn gehabt haben, wie auch die MKF-6, diese Weltraumkamera von Zeiss, die dann in die Station 6 stationär eingebaut wurde. Alles kann man heutzutage militärisch nutzen. Vieles geht von den militärischen Nutzungsabsichten aus und wird dann in die Industrie zurück exportiert. Wobei mir dieser Teflon-Pfann-Vergleich nicht besonders sympathisch ist. Also in der Teflon-Pfanne hätte man auch erfunden, ohne die Raumfahrt.
Vielleicht nochmal kurz in Ihre private Geschichte, was mich interessiert. Ich meine, Sie waren ja Flieger. Und wenn ich es richtig sehe, haben Sie so ziemlich alles geflogen, was der Fuhrpark so hergegeben hat an Jets.
Bis zu dem Zeitpunkt, ja. Dann später nicht mehr. Mit 29 habe ich nicht mehr fliegen können.
Aber eben auch die schnellen Jets, wo man auch schon extreme Belastungen ausgesetzt ist, was sicherlich auch einer der Gründe war, warum man jetzt ausgerechnet bei den Fliegern nach Raumfahrern gesucht hat.
Ganz genau, natürlich. Man wollte Leute haben, wo man auch eine gesundheitliche Akte hatte, wo man sicher war, da kann man nachschauen. Wenn ich schon zehn, 14 Jahre auf dem Puckel habe, wo man jährlich untersucht wird, da weiß man dann schon, ob der Mann vom Prinzip her zugelassen werden kann und sich eignet.
Haben Sie sich denn in dieser Fliegerei schon deshalb genähert, weil das sozusagen das Versprechen Raumfahrt mit sich gebracht hat?
Nein, das war mir schon zu alt damals. Vielleicht muss ich sagen, zu jung. Als Zürcher Gagarin in den Weltraumflug flog, war ich schon Flieger. Wir hörten dann, dass wir auf dem gleichen Flugzeugtypen fliegen. Das war damals dem X-17. Da war ein gewisser Stolz dabei, dass man aus den Fliegern die Leute rekordiert hat. Die Amerikaner haben das ja genauso gemacht. Aber dass ich jemals eine Chance gehabt oder für mich erdacht hätte, mal Raumfahrer zu werden, war völlig absurd für mich. Dass man überhaupt uns heranziehen würde aus der russischen Perspektive oder eben auch aus der amerikanischen. Es ist ja übrigens so gewesen, dass Ulf Merbel zum Beispiel und die westeuropäische Gruppe etwa zum gleichen Zeitpunkt schon im Visier waren. Also die Amerikaner wollten auch Leute mitnehmen. Aber sie haben es eben dann von der Technik her nicht gepackt. Also ich hatte nicht den Traum, nicht, dass ich ihn nicht hätte träumen wollen, aber ich hielt es für ab. Fühlte nicht realistisch.
Wie viel von dem, was man jetzt bei der Fliegerei so erlernt, hat man denn dann auch wirklich aktiv mitnehmen können in dieser Raumfahrt? Ist es jetzt nur die körperliche Belastung? Oder ist es auch schon von der Technik her, von dem, was man da, von dem, ich meine, man steuert ja die Raumkapsel nicht. Man wird ja im Wesentlichen nach oben geschossen. Da sitzt man nicht mehr am Lenkrad. Insofern ist es wirklich was anderes. Aber gibt es auch Dinge, die man dort hat mitnehmen können? Inwiefern ist diese Fliegerei verbunden mit der Raumfahrt?
Erst mal haben Sie völlig recht, dass man während des Starts nichts bewirken kann. Man kann nur abwarten und hoffen, dass es funktioniert. Dann gibt es schon Dinge. Wenn man das Raumfahrzeug selbst steuert, oder wir wurden ja als Ingenieur ausgebildet, wir waren zwei Mann im Raumschiff, also Commander und Ingenieur, da ist das schon von Nutzen, auch beim Erlernen der ganzen Dinge. Der dritte Mann ist dann schon eigentlich überflüssig, wenn man mit drei Mann fliegt. Da habe ich keine Zweifel, gerade wenn man diese Sache heute vergleicht. Was hat ein Tourist zu tun in einem russischen Raumschiff? Der hat im Wesentlichen nichts zu tun. Er muss wissen, wo er nicht hinfassen darf. Er muss den Funkverkehr führen. Er kann seine Dinge machen, die er sich vorstellt. Da gab es auch sehr intelligente Leute, die als Wissenschaftler geflogen sind, beiden Russen, von den Amerikanern zum Beispiel, ein Industrieller, der hatte seine eigenen Experimente erdacht und mitgenommen. Das war sicherlich für ihn nicht nur für Geld der Eindruck, den Weltraum zu sehen, sondern er hat vielleicht auch etwas mitgenommen für sein Unternehmen. Heute stellt sich immer mehr heraus, auch mit der Entwicklung der Technik, wir hatten damals keine neue Computer an Bord, die gab es noch nicht, dass man auch auf Flieger verzichten kann. Aber sowohl die Amerikaner als auch die Russen nehmen heute für die Kommandeursfunktion, als auch immer noch Piloten. Ich glaube, da ist schon eine gute Basis da.
Also eine gute Basis an technischem Verständnis, aber auch was die psychologische Belastung betrifft?
Auch das. Natürlich gibt es auch Leute, die irgendwo herumsitzen als Computer-Fachleute, die den gleichen Hintergrund psychologisch mitbrichten. Das muss man nicht voraussetzen. Aber es ist eine gute Basis.
Ist die physische Belastung vergleichbar? Wie ist es, wenn man in so einer MIG fliegt?
Die physische Belastung ist nur relevant beim Start und bei der Landung. Da hat man Überlastungen.
Also im Start, in der Raumfahrt?
In der Raumfahrt, ja. Beim Flugzeug ständig, aber da kann man das übertragen. Wenn man in Looping fliegt, hat man Überlastungen auch. Überlastungen im Sinne des Mehrfachen der normalen Erdanziehungskraft. Wenn ich sage, wir werden angezogen mit 1 g oder mit der Maßzahl 1. Und ich mache eine Vollkurve, steile Vollkurve im Jagdflugzeug, da kann ich schon 4, 5, 6 g erreichen. Dann bin ich 4, 5, 6 mal so schwer, durch den Arm kaum hoch. Das kann man ähnlich verspüren beim Start einer Rakete. Da ist es ungefähr 4 g, auch nicht mehr. Länger, aber für einen gesunden Menschen kein Problem. Kritisch kann es werden, wenn zum Beispiel beim Start die Rakete versagt und die Kapsel wird rauskatapultiert. Dann treten noch schon mal 18, 19, 20 g auf, allerdings sehr kurzfristig. Das ist schon ein Kriterium für die Auswahl. In einem Halbbranchen sollte man auch nicht in eine Kapsel setzen, auch wenn er nichts zu tun hat. Ich glaube schon, dass wir gut beraten waren. Das war ja auch nicht die Ausbildungszeit so lange, dass man Flugzeugführer war.
Wie ging es denn mit dieser Ausbildung voran? Was muss man denn erlernen, um taugtig zu sein für so einen Flug?
Wir hatten eine größere Nähe zu den Anforderungen, die man eben an den Kommandanten auch stellt. Wir hatten Ballistik, ein halbes Jahr Theorie. Die brachen der Flugbahnberechnungen zu lernen. Das war ein ganz schwieriges Thema. Vor allem die Technik des Raumschiffes. In der Theorie schalte ich das zwischen einem Raumschiff und einem Flugzeug heraus, außer den gesundheitlichen Aspekten und den Belastungsaspekten kaum Parallelen ergeben. Ein Flugzeug bewegt sich in einem Medium, genau wie ein Schiff. Man fliegt ein Radius, wenn man eine Kurve machen will. Es gibt ganz andere dynamische Hintergründe. Ein Raumschiff kann sich auch um alle Achsen bewegen. Aber wenn man die Horizontalgeschwindigkeit außer Acht lässt, diese 28.000 kmh, mit der die Kohler fliegt, dann bewegt es sich auf der Stelle, also um den Massenschwerpunkt. Man kann auch den Massenschwerpunkt verlagern, währenddessen sich ein Flugzeug immer in einem Medium bewegt. Also ganz andere flugdynamische Grundlagen vorherrschen.
In einem Weltraum gibt es da nur ein bisschen dunkle Materie und die merkt man nicht.
Das kann man so und so betrachten.
Die Ausbildung fand ja dann bei Moskau statt, in diesen sagenumwobenen Sternenstädtchen. Wie heißt das auf Russisch offiziell?
Svjostni Gordodok heißt das eigentlich. Svjostni Gordodok, wirklich. Svjostda heißt der Stern. Ist auch nicht ganz korrekt. Das Sternenstädtchen ist der Ort, in dem diese Ausbildung stattfindet. Das Ausbildungszentrum, das Cosmonauten-Ausbildungszentrum, Juri Gagarin auf Deutsch, das befindet sich in diesem Ort, den man Sternenstädtchen nennt. Das Sternenstädtchen, da gibt es also Geschäfte und eine medizinische Klinik und alles, was dazugehört. Da wohnen die Leute. Und dann ist noch mal abgetrennt eine Dienstzone. Das ist dann das Ausbildungszentrum.
Und das war dann das erste Mal, als sie da waren. Wir haben das vorher noch nie gesehen.
Doch, ich hatte das mal gesehen, als wir zum Studium waren auf der Militärakademie. Da hatten wir mal eine Exkursion dahin.
Sie hatten durch die Ausbildung ohnehin schon einen relativ guten Einblick in die russische Seele an der Stelle. Was zeichnet die Herangehensweise der Russen an das Thema Raumfahrt aus? Ganz offensichtlich wird es dort auch mit einem großen Pathos und auch mit einem großen Sportsgeist betrieben. Der Wettlauf mit den Amerikanern spielt natürlich auch immer eine große Rolle. Aber was haben Sie denn so für einen Eindruck gehabt, was diese Gemeinde dort treibt und wie die Herangehensweise ist?
Ich muss sagen, dass mir, wenn Sie von russischer Seele sprechen, dabei sehr viel geholfen haben, dass ich eine gewisse Affinität zu dieser Seele, die es natürlich nicht gibt, hatte. Also ich habe sehr viel zu tun gehabt als Flieger mit Russen hier in der DDR. Ich war, wie gesagt, Inspekteur Flug-Sicherheit, mit Flugunfällen befasst, wenn es da mal ganz kriminell wurde, wo man nicht genau wusste, hatte man nicht genug Material, habe ich mich mit einem Partner verständigen können, vor allen Dingen nach der Militärakademie, wo man russisch konnte, der hier in Wien-Sdorf saß, in der Gruppe der sowjetischen Streitkräfte oder der Luftstreitkräfte. Und wenn die Sprache nicht fremd ist eines anderen, eines anderen Landes, dann hat man auch viel mehr Möglichkeiten, das Ganze Unterschiedliche im Verhalten zu verinnerlichen. Ich habe mich, ich mache mal jetzt einen Sprung, ich habe mich sehr gefreut, ich konnte mit den Russen, sagen wir mal, das so. Als ich dann, nach 1990, mit den beiden ersten, jetzt muss ich wieder sagen, Westdeutschen, in Anführungsstrichen, es war genau ein Jahr nach dieser Mauergeschichte, in Moskau zog, in meinen Sternenstädtchen, mit den beiden Neulingen, das war der Klaus-Tieter Flade, Klaus-Tietrich Flade, Obersteleutnant der Luftwaffe und Reinhard Ewald, Physiker, habe ich mich gefreut, dass sie diese anfängliche Distanz, sage ich mal vorsichtig, bei Zeiten überwunden haben. Sie haben auch Freunde gefunden, die haben sich in den Familien angenähert, das, was ich schon lange hinter mir hatte. Dann ist da wenig übrig von großen Polemiken, von politischem Überbau, der das möglicherweise steuert. Dann gibt es einfach eine gemeinsame Arbeit. Das ist dann sowohl im Raumschiff so, als auch schon in diesem Sternenstädt. Man hat gemeinsam eine Aufgabe. Man fragt nicht mehr, was der der Russe ist und der der Deutsche, der vielleicht aus der Ukraine kommt oder in diesem Riesenland aus Ewenkien.
Aber es gibt ja trotzdem eine gewisse kulturelle Eigenschaft, der Länder an Sachen ranzugehen. Die Deutschen haben natürlich auch immer so ihr eigenes Verständnis von Pflichtbewusstsein und Wertarbeit. Ich will jetzt nicht so sehr in Klischees abgleiten, aber es gibt halt einfach eine bestimmte Art. So hat man es gelernt, so ist man groß geworden. Dann kommt man in ein anderes Land. Dort setzen die Leute sich auch intensiv mit Wissenschaft auseinander. War das dann im Prinzip genau das Gleiche? Oder gab es Dinge, auf die man gestoßen ist, wo man sagt, hier wird da und damit anders herangegangen? Das ist ja interessant.
Das ist alles das Gleiche. Das sind ernsthafte Leute. Es geht um Raumfort. Es ist natürlich auch eine bestimmte Einrichtung, die nicht irgendwas darstellt. Aber das war beim Militär genauso. Beim Militär oder bei der Fliegerei, da kann man natürlich Schlumperei nicht gebrauchen.
Ich habe ja vorhin ein paar Ausgaben auch schon mit Reinhold Ewald gesprochen. Wir hatten vor allem Raumstationen im Visier, im Thema, wo schon manches zur Sprache kam, darüber. Auch da habe ich schon ein bisschen versucht, so ein bisschen herauszulesen, was so eben die handwerklichen Unterschiede ausmacht. Gerade bei der Herangehensweise an Raumstationen haben sich der Russensee natürlich extrem hervorgetan. Also da war es offensichtlich sehr früh klar, dass man auf dieses Konzept Raumstation setzt, das ausgebaut hat, während die Amerikaner über das Skylab lange Zeit nicht hinausgekommen sind und sich auf andere Missionen konzentriert haben.
Wo ist das Transportsystem, das Shuttle eben?
Genau, die Wiederverwendbarkeit. Also ich frage mich halt, ob das einen kulturellen Grund hat oder ob es eher nur Zufall ist, dass die technischen Entwicklungen da zumindest eine Zeit lang so divergierten und sich eben in der russischen Raumfahrt der Schwerpunktraumstation so früh, so stark herausgebildet hatten, ja auch sehr erfolgreich war, wenn man sieht, wo es heute hingeführt hat.
Ich glaube, das war eine Strategie. Geht womöglich noch auf den Koroliov zurück. Darauf ist diese Identitätsperson der russischen Raumfahrt verbleichbar mit dem Bernher von Braun dann in den USA. Ich glaube, das war eine kluge Entscheidung, auf die Entwicklung von Langzeitfliegen zu setzen und die Technik dazu zu schaffen. Shuttle scheint mir fast eine Forderung der Industrie gewesen zu sein. Sie haben, wie gesagt, abrupt aufgehört mit Skylab und haben eben dieses System Shuttle geschaffen, was natürlich von der Tragfähigkeit, von der Möglichkeit, Massen in den Weltraum zu bringen, gerade für den Bau der neuen Raumstation, sehr effizient war. Ohne Shuttle hätte die Raumstation nicht die Konfiguration, wie sie heute hatte, eindeutig. Aber wenn man diese Soyuz-Raumschiffe, die ja viel pragmatischer, einfacher, robuster sind, nicht gehabt hätte, wäre die Raumstation auch nicht das, was sie heute ist. Im Prinzip wird sie heute angeflogen. Im Moment, in diesen Jahren, auf Kontaktbasis mit den Amerikanern, nur von den Shuttlen. Also die Raumstation kann nur leben durch den Transport der russischen Soyuz-Raumschiffe. Im Moment. Die Amerikaner arbeiten daran, natürlich in der Privatindustrie eigene Schiffe zu bauen usw. Ich weiß nicht, ob das...
Also am Ende hat es sich ergänzt?
Am Ende war es das ideale System. Ich war ja immer drüben in Moskau, wo die ersten Amerikaner kamen und so. Es war der Traum eigentlich in dieser ganzen auch politischen Konstellation der Jahre. Jetzt zeigt die Raumfahrt, was sie kann, dachte ich. Sie vereinigt auf technischer Basis die Menschen und für die Fachleute aus den USA und aus Russland und den Ländern, die mitarbeiten. Es war ja ganz Europa in Moskau über die ESA. Ein Wissenschaftler, die dann ihre Experimente bebrachten. Das war das ideale Bild, wie man sich Raumfahrt auch als Motor für die friedliche Annäherung der Nationen vorstellte, ich persönlich. Und da gab es auch so gut wie keine spürbaren Unterschiede in dem Verhalten der Fachleute, der Amerikaner wiederum, mit den Russen. Auf der Ebene, wo Leute arbeiten, wo sie auch gemeinsam in einem... Blechsaal, hätte ich fast gesagt, in einem Raumschiff sitzen, wo es überhaupt keine Diskussion geben kann. Bist du besonders pflichtbewusst und du vielleicht literlicher oder trinkst du gar nicht mal einen Wodka, nicht mal einen Wein, da spielt das alles keine Rolle. Da geht es um die gemeinsame Aufgabe. Die Probleme gehen nur los, wo es in die höheren Etagen geht, wo es auch ein bisschen um Einfluss, um Persönliches, um Machtbeflissenheit geht, vielleicht auch um politisches Durchsetzungsvermögen. Das ist mein Eindruck.
Ja, in gewisser Hinsicht sind so die Raumfahrtprogramme mit ihrer internationalen Kooperation, leben sie ja so eine Art Ideal vor.
So ist es, ja. So ist es. Vielleicht ist das auch. Nun gibt es wieder den Touch, oder die Richtung in die bezahlte Raumfahrt, aber das wäre ein Thema für sich, ist halt so.
Bezahlt im Sinne von Tourismus.
Ja, Tourismus, ja.
Da bleiben wir erstmal noch mal so ein bisschen bei der Wissenschaft. Mich interessiert jetzt nochmal auch, jetzt ihr erster Flug zu lernen. Ist es auch von Saljut oder Salut 6? Ich bin es großartig richtig.
Ich muss sagen, so ein bisschen Saljut, so ein bisschen weicher.
So ein bisschen, okay. Die Mission hat wie lange gedauert insgesamt? Es war auch schon erheblicher.
Nein, wir sind integriert gewesen in eine Langzeitbesatzung, die 140 Tage als Aufgabenstellung hatte. Es kamen angedockte, wo sie 74 Tage weg hatten. Und wir haben nur eine Woche gemeinsam gearbeitet.
Wie muss man sich das vorstellen? Wir hatten jetzt die Pflegerei im Hintergrund. Klar, jetzt übt man und trainiert und man hat wahrscheinlich eine extrem klare Vorstellung davon, was einen erwartet, weil der gesamte Flugprozess vermutlich minutiös durchmarschiert worden ist, viele Male, sodass man einem nicht im einlichen Sinne überrascht sein dürfte. Ist man dann trotzdem überrascht, wenn es losgeht?
Natürlich ist man überrascht. Ich meine, man hat mal Ja gesagt und dann muss man auch den Eindruck erwecken, dass man mutig und tapfer ist. Obwohl man natürlich auch als Flieger, das muss man schon abhalten und das zeigt man auch nicht. Ich behaupte, ich hatte keine Angst. Weil ich auch der klaren Auffassung bin, Angst ist nicht helfend. Das hat man bei Flugzeugen, wenn man da beim Start dran denkt, es könnte durch das Triebwerk ausfallen. Frühere Flugzeugtypen hatten keine Katapulteinrichtungen, die man auch beim Start nutzen konnte. Da musste man mindestens 250, 300 Meter Höhe haben. Ich habe das mal erlebt, habe ich mal katapultiert. Wenn ich von 300 Metern kam, dann hat das keinen Sinn mehr, darüber nachzudenken, ob ich Angst habe oder nicht. Dass einem der Puls hochgeht, dass man emotional erregt ist, das ist ein ganz anderes Thema. Da braucht man nichts dazu tun, das macht der Körper automatisch. Überraschungen gibt es am laufenden Band, dass die Erde rund ist, dass man das so sieht. Das ist alles klar vorher. Mathematik und Physik.
Aber das ist dann auch wirklich so.
Das ist schon verrückt. Dass man die Erde in 90 Minuten umrundet und dass dann jedes Mal die Sonne aufgeht und sie auch runtergeht. Dass am Tag 16-mal das erlebt wird, das ist schon ein Höhepunkt. Selbst im Leben möchte ich schon noch mal leben. Aber das habe ich natürlich abgeschrieben. Aber das bleibt ein, eben. Ansonsten weiß man, dass man arbeiten muss, dass man keinen Fehler zulassen darf. Nicht einen einzigen nach Möglichkeit. Und ich muss sagen, ich hatte keine Probleme mit der Gesundheit. Ich hatte nicht diese Dinge, die sehr oft auftreten, dass man dann eben, was ein Ibel wird, die ersten Tage oder Stunden konnte arbeiten. Und dann habe ich mein Experimentierprogramm gemacht. Da waren verschiedene Fachrichtungen. Ich hätte mir gewünscht, dass ich mich noch besser vorbereitet hätte.
Noch besser? Worauf ist man eigentlich vorbereitet?
Ich hätte mir zum Beispiel gewünscht, ein hochauflösendes Gerät zu haben, um Polarlichterscheinungen zu fotografieren. Die Filme gaben das nicht her. Dieses Spektrum würde es sicherlich heute besser alleine schulen.
Das heißt, man könnte das, was man eigentlich selbst dort wahrnahm, gar nicht so richtig aufzeichnen?
Gar nicht so schnell aufzeichnen. Heute hat man da viel mehr Möglichkeiten. Wir hatten ja, wie gesagt, auch nicht mal einen Computer. Aber alleine schon, dass man eben auch medizinische Experimente, dass man um die Erde fliegt und zu einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt ein Experiment beginnt. Man macht sich die Elektroden an und der Arzt unten hat den Blutdruck und den Puls usw. Oder sagt, pass mal auf, die linke Elektrode hier oben, die sitzt nicht so richtig. Das sind zwar Kleinigkeiten, technisch alles erklärbar, aber das sind eben Dinge, wo man auch das Staunen nicht verlernen sollte.
Ja, das ist schon, dass man von der Erde ferngesteuert wird. Was denkt man denn so über den Planeten, wenn man ihn so von oben sieht? Was war denn so ihr Eindruck?
Na, ich glaube, da denken alle das Gleiche. Ich habe mit Amerikanern später zu tun gehabt, egal mit wem, da spielt die Nationalität auch keine Rolle, dass man uns immer halten sollte. Vielleicht kommt einem diese Gedanken auch später. Oben ist alles normal. Man ist im Raumflug. Und arbeitet und guckt auf die Uhr und schreibt auf.
Alltag.
Alltag, ja. Man denkt schon gar nicht mehr daran, dass das was ganz Verrücktes ist. Ja, und hinterher, wenn man dich fragt, dann sagt man eben möglichst gescheite Worte. Aber auch nicht beabsichtigt. Man denkt dann, es ist schon so. Ich habe dann auch schon mal so gesagt, die Menschen können Raumschiffe bauen, sie können Raumstationen bauen. Sie haben mit diesen Elektronikgeschichten einen enormen Fortschritt gemacht, diese Computergeschichten, technischen, wissenschaftlichen Fortschritt gemacht in den letzten, ruhig, 100 Jahren oder vielleicht in den letzten 10 Jahren. Aber in der Sinne, da schicken wir unsere Jungs nach Afghanistan, damit sie sich den Kopf einschlagen lassen oder anderen Leuten den Kopf einschlagen. Also der Diskrepanz, finde ich, in der Entwicklung der Menschheit, zwischen der technischen, wissenschaftlichen Entwicklung und der moralisch-ethischen, die ist ungefähr so, wie eben das heute zur Steinzeit, finde ich.
Das wird einem da oben nochmal extra bewusst?
Ob mir das dann oben schon bewusst wurde, oder später, weiß ich nicht.
Das hat sich schon dadurch eingestellt?
Das hat sich eingestellt, natürlich. Du siehst da irgendwelche Schlote, Quallen, in der Drigei zum Beispiel, oder irgendwo, wo du siehst, dass die Abgase, CO2, Stichwort über hunderte Kilometer getragen werden, oder dass dort eben Wüsten einerseits bewässert werden können. Das sieht man teilweise in regelrechten Kreisen, das habe ich damals schon gesehen, wo eben was wächst, weil da eine Beregnungsanlage ist. Das fällt alles mit einem Blick auf, was man alles machen kann und was man in Wirklichkeit macht, wenn man sich durcheist gegeneinander.
Man kriegt einen ganz anderen Überblick.
Ja, und auch eine andere Gedankenwelt. Aber das habe ich gespürt bei den meisten Raumfahrern, egal wo sie herkamen.
Dieser Wettlauf, eine Weile lang war es ein Wettlauf zwischen den Amerikanern und den Russen. Inwiefern hat man sich da selbst als Teil davon gefühlt? War das eher so eine sportliche Herausforderung? Oder inwiefern merkt man, dass da auch ein politischer Druck dahintersteht? Was hat die Programme wirklich nach vorne getrieben? War es so, dass es wirklich von den Wissenschaftlern getragen war und dass die im Prinzip die Zielvorgaben gemacht haben? Man hatte das Gefühl, man musste zwar gegen eine Bürokratie anlaufen, aber man hat dann auch gewonnen. Oder hat man immer das Gefühl, dass man eigentlich nicht immer in die richtige Richtung rennt?
Ich habe mich auf dieser Ebene nicht bewegt, wo politische Entscheidungen getroffen waren. Aber wenn ich mal zurückgehe auf die Zeit, in der der erste Flug vorbereitet wurde, Juri Gagarin's Flug, da war schon klar, ich meine, es gab, ich müsste anfangen bei dem Hermann Obert. Die großen Denker auf der russischen Seite war C. Alkovski in Deutschland nach dem ersten Weltkrieg, um den ersten Weltkrieg schon war es Hermann Obert, die die wissenschaftlichen Grundlagen für die Raumfahrt geschaffen haben. Die haben gesagt, ein Raketer muss her. Jules Verne mit dem Geschoss auf den Mond, das geht nicht. Also es muss eine Flüssigkeitsrakete gebaut werden. Die haben die Formeln dazu gefunden. Oder eben, die Formeln lagen ja irgendwo in der Natur oder Dinge, aber sie haben sie aufgeschrieben. Und dann haben sich gerade in Deutschland nach dem ersten Weltkrieg Leute gefunden, die mit dem Basteln angefangen haben von Raketen und die Vereine gebildet haben, die wir wollen in den Weltraum. Erstaunlich, wie die das formuliert haben damals in den zwanzig Jahren. Wir, eine Gemeinschaft, ein Verein, der sich das Ziel stellt, Flüge in den Weltraum in den nächsten Jahrzehnten vorzubereiten. Zwanzig Jahre.
Die waren bestimmt die Verrückten.
Das waren auch Bastler, die deshalb gebastelt haben, weil das nicht verboten war. Der Erste Weltkrieg war verloren gegangen und die Siegermächte haben bestimmt, in Deutschland dürfen keine Flugzeuge gebaut werden, keine Waffen, diese und jenes. Raketen zu verbieten, hatten sie verboten, weil es noch keine gab. In den 30er Jahren schon hatte sich der von Braun, als junger, tatkräftiger und einflussreicher Ingenieur, schon mit diesen Dingen befasst. Hat die Berliner Gruppe, das war die stärkste, die erfolgreichste, die hatten dann schon Raketen, die so 500 Meter hochflogen, in den 30er Jahren. Und auch so, wie man rechnet, auch 90 Kilometer weit. Will ich mich mal nicht festlegen. Auf jeden Fall das Militär erkannte die Tragfähigkeit dieser Entwicklung. Es gab Geld von Braun Zuck mit seinen Leuten, die uns kennengelernt hatten, von Kummersdorf, wo die Heeresversuchsanstalt war, nach Binnemünde. Und bereits am 3. Oktober 1942 wurde von dieser Rakete, einer dieser Raketen, der Weltraum angekratzt. Also mit einer Höhe von 90 Kilometern, die so eine Rakete hatte, und nicht nur 200 und ein paar Kilometer Reichweite.
Und bei 100 geht es los, je nach Definition?
Ja, je nach Definition. Man kann schon eben sagen, der Weltraum war angekratzt. Ja, und nun kann man diese Entwicklung verteufeln, nur verteufeln, weil ja dann in England diese Dinger einschlugen, Coventry.
Weil das der A4, die V2 wurde?
Weil es der A4, dem Triebwerk, die A2 wurde. Aber die Siegermächte hatten nichts Eiligeres zu tun und Wichtigeres zu tun, als sich dieser Entwicklung zu nähern und ihr habhaft zu werden. Von Braun hat sich mit allen seinen Unterlagen und den besten Leuten, den Amerikanern selbst gestellt hat, gesagt, wir wollen weitermachen für sie. Und die Russen haben sich, ich will nicht sagen den Rest, aber auch gute Leute gesucht, haben in Deutschland noch ein paar Raketen gefunden oder zusammengebaut und sind dann hingezogen. Also der Anfang war dann auf beiden Seiten dieses A4, das ist das leistungsstärkste Raketentriebwerk der damaligen Zeit, was es gab. Und so war klar, erst bauen wir die ballistische Rakete, um die damals entstandenen Atomwaffen um die Welt zu schießen, schießen zu können und daraus entstand der Wettlauf um den Sputnik erstmal. Dann hatten sie gewonnen und dann um den ersten Menschen. Dann war schon klar, dass man den Start eines Menschen erwarten kann. Und die Russen haben gewusst, dass die weite Amerikaner sind. Die waren vielleicht nicht ganz so weit und so klar.
Die Amerikaner waren dann doch überrascht, dass es den Russen gelungen ist.
Ja, aber die Russen haben auch, wenn man das genau verfolgt, ein relativ hohes Risiko eingegangen. Natürlich wurden dann mal bestimmte Raketen gestartet und dann wurden die Misserfolge ausgewertet. Am Ende war man sich doch sicher, wir kriegen Gagarin zurück auf die Erde. Aber es war ein hohes Risiko und es war auch politischer Druck dahinter. Man wusste schon in Moskau...
Wie waren denn seine Chancen, lebend wieder zurückzukommen?
Am Ende zählt nur der Erfolg, er kam lebend zurück. Aber es gab auch während dieses Fluges eine Menge Ausfälle. Es gab ernsthafte Ausfälle, was hätte auch schiefgehen können.
Was ist da passiert?
Was ist passiert zum Beispiel? Es geht ja immer einfach los. Ein Ventil hat zuzeitig aufgehört zu arbeiten. Es ist Kraftstoff ausgetreten, beim Einleiten des Bremsvorgangs, also das Bremstriebwerk bei der Rückkehr, hat eine Sekunde zu früh aufgehört zu arbeiten. Dadurch hat das Zeitzyklogramm insgesamt nicht mehr funktioniert. Die Trennung des Raumschiffes ist nicht erfolgt nach dem Zeitzyklogramm. Und es trat automatisch der Fall ein, dass die Trennung durch die Hitzeeinwirkung in der Atmosphäre erfolgte. Er hatte also zehn Minuten sozusagen zu warten, bis durch Temperaturgeber, bei uns war das auch so, bei etwa 150 Grad Hitze dann die Sprengpatronen auslösten. Das war zum Beispiel doch ein recht solider Ausfall. Und dann hatte auch aus diesem Grund, dass das Zyklogramm nicht richtig abarbeitete, bekam die Kapsel eine Rotation, ich glaube, von 30 Grad pro Sekunde. Das ist schon ganz ordentlich. Und er hat es auch dann beschrieben, mehr humoristisch beschrieben. Das war wie im Kino, wie im Salto Mortale. Ich habe den Eindruck, jetzt sehe ich den Horizont, dann sehe ich wieder mal den schwarzen Himmel. Und dann hat die Sonne geblendet, drehte mich laufend.
Sehr unangenehm war es schon.
Sehr unangenehm natürlich. Aber er hat das mit Humor getragen. Ich weiß ja auch, wenn er rauswärte.
Aber ihn kennengelernt haben sie nicht, er ist ja früh gestorben.
Er ist früh abgestürzt, ja. Das war die Zeit auf der Militärakademie. Das war am 27. April 1968. Ich hörte davon eines Morgens, sagte mir jemand, der Kameraden ist abgestürzt. Die flogen immer über diese Akademie. Wie gesagt, die beiden Einrichtungen sind in unmittelbarer Nähe. Da wird viel, wenn es um diesen Absturz geht, vor allen Dingen in Russland, geteudelt. Journalisten wollen immer was haben, wo sie eine große Story abziehen können. Als wäre er nicht wirklich abgestürzt, sondern vielleicht sogar von der Regierung irgendwo in einem Brückenheim. Das ist alles Quatsch. Das ist die Schwerungstheorie. Er wollte unbedingt fliegen, eindeutig. Er wollte das Mondprogramm mitmachen, das Russische. Da haben sie ihn auch erst gelassen, als Backup von Komarov, der auch mit seinem Raumschiff abstürzte. Das war der erste Flug mit dem neuen Raumschiff, mit dem Soyuz-Raumschiff. Da war Gagarin Backup. Als das passierte, hat man ihn aus der Raumfahrt rausgenommen, hat man ihm verboten, weiter mitzumachen als Testpilote, als Testraumfahrer. Dann hat er sich aber stark darum gemüht, dass er weiter mit Jagdflugzeugen fliegen durfte. Er hat nach einer langen Pause wieder angefangen und dieser Flug ging eben schief. Da wir wegen Wetterbedingungen und anderen Dingen eine Rolle gespielt haben, darüber zu deuteln, bringt nichts.
Wenn man sich dieses hohe Risiko anschaut, was ja wohl bei den ersten Missionen gang und gäbe gewesen ist. Die Technik war alles noch in der Entwicklung. Im Prinzip wusste man ja alles noch gar nicht, was man eigentlich so für Systeme bräuchte. Man nimmt halt immer an, dass das und das passieren würde. Das wird sich in vielen Fällen eingestellt haben, aber in manchen dann wahrscheinlich nicht. So dass dann die nächste Entwicklung das Risiko wieder minimiert hat. Aber es war ja eigentlich wirklich ein bisschen wilder Westen. Man war eigentlich permanent in Gefahr, also als Kosmonaut, als Mensch im All, weil man eine enormen Gefahr ausgesetzt durch das Unbekannte und vor allem das Unbekannte der Zuverlässigkeit der Technik. Wie hat sich denn das, ich meine, kann man jetzt die bemannte Raumfahrt, so wie sie sich bis heute abzeichnet, in so Phasen unterteilen, dass man sagt, so diese wilde Zeit, das hat dann auch mit irgendeiner Entwicklung ein Ende genommen oder sind das so fließende Übergänge oder hat sich vielleicht gar nichts geändert? Ich meine, die Gefahren sind natürlich auch heute noch da.
Die Gefahren sind auch heute noch da, tatsächlich. Sie sehen ja, von den fünf Shuttle, auch in der neueren Zeit, haben zwei nicht überlebt. Es sind natürlich noch kleinere Mängel, aber letzten Endes führen sie eben bei der Luftfahrt oder auch bei der Raumfahrt zu großen Folgen.
Challenger beim Start, Columbia beim Wiedereintritt.
Insofern, bei der Raumfahrt darf es eben keine Schluterei geben. Wenn man das manchmal liest, ich habe das nicht kennengelernt, die ersten Jahre auf diesem Polygon, da war dieser Korolev, der Chef, der war derart ungnädig, dass er Leute, die einen kleinen Fehler zugelassen haben, weggejagt hat, auf Nimmerwiedersehen. Da hat er nichts verziehen. Da mag schon so ein bisschen, wenn Sie vorhin von deutscher Gründlichkeit sprachen, das könnte schon gewesen sein, weil ja, was sich in Deutschland vielleicht über Jahrzehnte schon durchzieht, die Forderung bei technischen Entwicklungen, besonders gründlich zu sein, das hat er in Russland später eingesetzt und ist vielleicht hier und da auch noch so ein bisschen ein Charakterzug, das Leben lockerer zu nehmen. Aber da bin ich sehr vorsichtig mit Beurteilungen.
Aber dadurch hat es sich auf jeden Fall gewandelt.
Ja, ganz bestimmt. Also, ich habe mal in Paris die Ariane Rakete, bei Paris gesehen, mit Ingenieuren, auch aus Deutschland. Da sagt einer von diesen, der Raumfahrten nahestehenden Leuten mit einem guten Namen, ich würde mich nie in so ein Ding reinsetzen, wenn man weiß, was da alles an Kleinigkeiten drin ist.
Ja, ich glaube, das ist auch, denke ich, so eine Eigenschaft der Techniker, die dieses Thema gut verstehen. Und wenn ich jedes Detail kenne, dann wissen wir, an wie vielen Stellen es auseinanderklappen kann. Das ist auch im Computerbereich anders. Und man wundert sich dann immer überhaupt nicht, wenn irgendjemand mal in Probleme gerät. Man wundert sich eigentlich mehr darüber, dass es nicht häufiger passiert. Das ist mal wieder so ein Punkt. Aber inwiefern hat denn jetzt die technologische Entwicklung oder auch die organisatorische Entwicklung in der Raumfahrt da einen Wandel herbeigeführt? Hat es sich grundlegend geändert? Ist das Risiko immer noch genauso groß? Wird auf Sicherheit mehr wertgelegt als am Anfang?
Ich glaube schon, dass den Machern von Anfang an klar war, dass es hier auf besondere Gründlichkeit ankommt. Jedes System muss erstmal ein paar Testläufe bestehen. Dann wird klar, wo die Schwachstellen sind. Das ist heute weitgehend ausgereifter geworden, sowohl im Westen als auch im Osten, wenn man das so sagen möchte. Aber dieses technische Feld, Raumfahrt, genau wie Luftfahrt, ist eben nicht zu vergleichen mit Gartenbau. Wenn ich meine Radieschen ernten will, dann gehe ich nicht gefahr dabei, derart abzustürzen, dass ich mir das Leben verliere. Das muss man schon sehen. Die Computers sind auch sehr, sehr schwierig. Sie helfen natürlich auch bei der Raumfahrt. Aber sie können auch Schaden anrichten, wo er eben ausfällt.
Wie muss man denn die Komplexität der Raumfahrt bewerten? Machen die Computer die Sache jetzt eher einfacher oder machen sie es am Ende sogar noch komplexer, weil man immer meint, noch sehr viel mehr beherrschen zu können? Oder hat es die Sache schon so vereinfacht, dass man sagen kann, in Zukunft werden sehr viel komplexere Herausforderungen noch sehr viel einfacher zu bewältigen sein, als man sich das heute vorstellt?
Es wäre ja Nonsens, wenn man Computer hätte und sie nicht nutzen würde in der Raumfahrt. Insofern sind die Computer...
Ich meine, die Komplexität der Programme. Wenn man heute ein neues Programm aufsetzt, eine Herrscher von Wissenschaftlern muss sich um alle möglichen Aspekte kümmern. So dass die Koordination dieser ganzen Gruppen für sich schon mal eine riesige Herausforderung darstellt. Ich weiß nicht, wie viele Leute waren bei dem ersten Raumflug an diesem Projekt beteiligt?
Sicherlich auch Tausende.
Tausende.
Jedes Detail muss gemacht werden in zig Werken. Wir haben ja keine Schmiede gehabt in Baikonur oder in Amerika. Sondern dort muss alles laufen, was sonst auch läuft. Ich baue eine neue Maschine und weiß, das Ventil A beziehe ich von der Firma, das Ventil oder den Amortisator beziehe ich von daher. Das geht nicht so mit links.
Wie bewerten Sie denn so die aktuellen Entwicklungen? Wir haben ja schon ein bisschen darüber gesprochen, dass sich Amerikaner, Russen, Europäer in vielen Programmen schon gemeinsam finden. Die Russen bringen ihre Technik nach Kourou. Neben der Ariane wird dort auch Soyuz fliegen können. Man merkt, dass eine sehr viel stärkere Verflechtung der einzelnen Raumfahrtorganisationen stattfindet. Aber es gibt ja auch noch die Chinesen, die scheinen ja derzeit noch so ein bisschen außen vor zu sein und ihr eigenes Süppchen zu kochen. Wie ist das so zu bewerten?
Das sehe ich genauso wie sie. Obwohl die Chinesen sehr viel an Technologie gekauft haben, bei den Russen vor allen Dingen, lassen sie sich nicht in die Karten gucken. Über die Entwicklung von China zu spekulieren, wo das hinführt, man spricht ja davon, dass die Chinesen die Amerikaner ablesen und als Führungsmacht, aber das sind Felder, wo ich mich nicht auskenne. Manche Leute sagen, die Chinesen wollen die ersten auf dem Mars sein, aber das kann man auch als Spekulation abtun. Wenn ich von Traum spreche, mein Traum war mal in der Raumfahrt, dass sie wirklich echt dazu führt, dass die Nationen sich annähern, friedlich in die Zukunft reichen, in die Zukunft der Menschheit. Aber gerade in diese Richtung Mars-Programme...
Scheint es wieder einen größeren Wettbewerb zu geben.
Ja, genau, dass die Amerikaner ihr Programm machen, hat ja schon Bush mit seinem Constellation-Programm angedeutet. Wir werden Amerikaner wie immer vorangehend. Dann wird noch mal ein Wort dazu gesagt, Internationalität. Aber direkt aufgerufen, zu gleichberechtigter Zusammenarbeit ist zum Beispiel die Europäische Weltraumagentur nicht von den Amerikanern. Obama hat das wieder ein bisschen relativiert. Aber letzten Endes hat er auch gesagt, ich werde mir die Landung von Amerikanern auf dem Mond im Fernsehen noch anschauen, auf dem Mars noch anschauen. Das ist auch mehr Rhetorik als Realismus. Und die Chinesen bauen halt.
Wie bewerten Sie denn die bisher sichtbaren Fortschritte von dem, was man weiß?
Der Chinesen? Haben Sie Leute im Weltraum, bauen an einer Raumstation? Ganz sicher haben Sie die Erfahrung, vor allem der Russen genutzt und weiterentwickelt. Nicht das bloß gelassen und abgekupfert. Alles andere ist Spekulation. Auch für mich würde ich nicht machen wollen.
Aber auf jeden Fall kann man fast sagen, haben wir einen neuen Wettbewerb, aber der vielleicht letzten Endes dann auch zwangsläufig in einer Kooperation münden kann. Ist das überhaupt vorstellbar, dass solche komplexen Projekte, wie eine Landung eines Menschen auf dem Mars von einer einzigen Nation überhaupt noch gestimmt werden kann?
Den Chinesen würde ich es am ehesten zutragen.
Die Frauen, die einfach hochmotiviert sind.
Hochmotiviert und eine zentrale Führung, die einfach sagen kann, Geld spielt keine Rolle.
Wie hat sich denn aus Ihrer Erfahrung, als die Wende kam, DDR und Bundesrepublik Deutschland zusammengegangen sind und sich ja auch die ganze Situation in Osteuropa deutlich verändert hat. Das dürfte ja auch auf den Status quo der Raumfahrt, so wie sie sie bis dahin kennengelernt hatten, auch eine erhebliche Auswirkung gehabt haben. Auf einmal hat sich alles europäisiert, internationalisiert in einem Maße, wie es so vorher nicht stattgefunden hat. Sie haben es ja schon angedeutet, dass sie eben dann auch mit anderen deutschen Kosmonauten zusammengearbeitet haben. Und das drückt ja sozusagen auch diesen Schritt zur Internationalität aus. Welche Entwicklung sehen Sie da in Europa? Hat Raumfahrt dadurch mehr an Bedeutung gewonnen? Wie hat sich das Arbeiten dadurch verändert? Hat es sich überhaupt verändert?
Na ja, ich bin 1989 eigentlich schon ein bisschen integriert worden in die gesamtdeutsche Raumfahrtentwicklung. Wir waren ja getrennt. Es gab so gut wie keine Zusammenarbeit zwischen der DDR und der Bundesrepublik auf dem Gebiet, der technischen Raumfahrt. Im Gegensatz, wir wollten als DDR noch mal einen Flug machen. Ich war mit den Moskau zu Verhandlungen, das muss auch so 88, 89 gewesen sein, und uns wurde gesagt, Geld auf den Tisch. Diese Interkosmos-Korporation fing schon an zu bröckeln. Und wir hatten kein Geld und mussten wieder abziehen. Und fast zur gleichen Zeit, wie ich dann später erfahren habe, gab es schon Verhandlungen der Bundesrepublik, der alten Bundesrepublik mit den Russen. Denn sie hatten natürlich erkannt, sie haben einen Trumpf, die Russen. Wir flogen mehr oder weniger in diesem Interkosmos-Programm, wo Geld für die Sachen keine Rolle spielte, aber wo das Geld nicht die Rolle spielte. Wir haben nicht das bezahlt, was es gekostet hat. Das ist erstmal eindeutig. Aber inzwischen hatten die Russen das verstanden, auch auszunehmen, einzusetzen, international. Es flog zum Beispiel ein Inter-, es flog ein Franzose, es flog ein Syrien. Und die Westdeutschen hatten auch Verhandlungen schon angefangen. Und das war 1988, 1989, glaube ich. Und ich wurde schon eingeladen in die Bundesrepublik nach Köln zum DLR, um ein bisschen was zu erzählen über die russische Raumfahrt, wie es da vor sich geht. Sie hatten ja wenig Kontakte international, auch mit den Russen nicht. Oder in was nicht in der bekannten Raumfahrt. Und das war für mich andererseits dann auch der Sprung, als wir am Ende waren. Und ich meine, mein Dienstgradverlore und alles was dazugehörte. Dass man mir angeboten hat, eben mit nach Moskau zu gehen und sozusagen dort das erste Office aufzubauen. Und dann hat mich auch die ESA übernommen.
Das schlüpft sozusagen in eine Vermittlerrolle, kann man sagen.
Ja, genau. Natürlich. Es gehört schon ein bisschen was dazu. Das ist vielleicht der Berührungspunkt, wo man mit den Russen durchaus besser zurechtkommt, wenn man nicht irgendwie arrogant daherkommt. Jetzt wollen wir euch mal zeigen, wie irgendwas gemacht wird. Das sehen die Russen nicht gerne und haben ja auch ganz guten Grund dazu. Denn hinter Moen sind sie bei beiden nicht. Das ist ein Bild des Westens. Das Westen und in Deutschland vor allen Dingen, was immer wieder gepflegt wird. Besonders von bestimmten Medien.
Dass die russische Technologie veraltet ist.
Ja, genau.
Macht alles mit viel, aber nicht mit dem Detail.
Genau so ist es. Das stimmt nicht. Das stimmt nicht. Das stimmt bei beiden nicht. Vor allen Dingen, wenn man eben den Schlüssel kennt zu, sie haben das Wort russische Seele gesagt, dann ist man gleichberechtigt und anerkannt. Du kannst zum guten Freund werden. Meine persönliche Genugtuung war, dass das auch, gerade Thomas Reiter, auch Reinhold Ewald, ich meine eigentlich alle, eine mehr, der andere weniger, dass die das wie ein Aha-Erlebnis begriffen haben. Und das hat uns viel Gewinn gebracht. Natürlich ist das nur jetzt mal die Ebene der Raumfacher, auch Techniker, Ingenieure. Also ich darf sagen, gerade wenn es auf das DLR kommt, ich bin da aufgenommen worden als Gleichberechtigter. Ich habe auch viele Aha-Erlebnisse erlebt mit Spezialisten des Deutschen Zentrums Luft- und Raumfahrt. Und gerade auch, was die Rolle der Vorstandsvorsitzenden betrifft, Professor Wörner, gegenwärtig eine sehr große, kluge Offenheit zu diesen Dingen, auch mit den Partnern. Das kann man gar nicht hoch genug schätzen.
Was hat denn der Osten vom Westen dann lernen können in dieser Phase?
Das Miteinander hat schon viel gebracht, gerade wenn russische Delegationen in der Phase der Raumflüge, die waren natürlich auch in Deutschland, oder eben in, was über die ESA ging, ab 1993, begann die Zusammenarbeit in der bemannten Raumfahrt mit der ESA. Das habe ich von Anfang an miterlebt. Da gab es natürlich einen großen Delegationsaustausch. Die Sicherheitsleute waren bei ESA, haben sich vieles angeschaut, haben auch vieles mitgenommen.
Aber ich meine, genauso wie es Vorbehalte gegenüber den Russen gab im Westen, mag es ja auch in die andere Richtung so gewesen sein.
Natürlich, zum Beispiel gab es mal eine Idee auf der westlichen Seite bei einigen Leuten, aber das ist nicht meine Ebene, man könnte doch die russische Raumfahrt in die ESA integrieren. Wäre das ein Gedanke, wäre das ein tragbares Konzept? Am Ende wurde dann klar, das geht aus dem Grunde nicht, weil die russische Raumfahrt stärker ist als die europäische insgesamt. Da haben diese Worte es sagen. Man darf die russische Raumfahrt nicht unterschätzen. Wenn auch bestimmte technische Entwicklungen möglicherweise fortgeschrittener sind im Westen, allein schon aufgrund der besseren Technologie auf einigen Gebieten, bin ich aber auch kein Fachmann.
Ich denke, im Computerbereich hat auf jeden Fall der Westen Großes geleistet. Was war im Rahmen dieser Annäherung der Schritt, den der Osten nachvollziehen musste, um mit dem Westen klarzukommen?
Wie gesagt, auf der hohen Ebene bin ich nicht aussagekräftig. Ich habe zum Beispiel festgestellt –das ist aber ein winziges Detail, trotzdem ist es ein bestimmtes Maße charakteristisch –unsere Leute, die Astronauten, in den Anfang der 90er-Jahre waren noch Sowjetunion. Sie wurden damit konfrontiert, dass sie noch die Einwege spritzen. Sie waren sehr reserviert, dass sie das nicht machen. Das hat natürlich nicht nur Freude hervorgerufen. Natürlich war der Westen in bestimmten Dingen, gerade bei Kleinigkeiten weiter, die manchmal eine Rolle spielen. Der Mann kennt bestimmte medizinische Fortschritte und will die auch nicht zurückgehen auf ein anderes, niederes Niveau. Das fällt mir gerade so ein. Das ist vielleicht auf technischen Dingen auch so gewesen, auf bestimmten technischen Entwicklungen.
Was sehen Sie denn so derzeit als die wichtigste Entwicklung an? Vielleicht was die Raumfahrt an sich betrifft, aber eben auch konkret die bemannte Raumfahrt. Was sind so die derzeitigen Herausforderungen, von denen die gesamte Branche steht und womit sie sich derzeit aktiv auch auseinandersetzt oder auseinandersetzen sollte, wenn es noch nicht in dem Maße geschieht?
Ich denke, die Voraussagen, die vor 30 Jahren gemacht wurden, dass die bemannte Raumfahrt auch über drei Beberge von Brot bringt. Also symbolisch betrachtet, dass die Raumfahrt an sich alles revolutioniert hat. Das brauchen wir ja nicht mal diskutieren. Mit den Satelliten und mit allem. Aber die bemannte Raumfahrt hat meines Erachtens noch nicht bewiesen, dass sie wirtschaftlich gesehen auch das wiederbringt, was in sie reingesteckt wird. Was jetzt passiert mit dem Tourismus, ist ja eigentlich nur ein Nebenfeld. Wenn die Raumfahrt zu nur Tourismus verkommen würde, finde ich, wäre das sehr schade. Also das Zeichen dafür, dass das noch nicht richtig läuft, ist, dass die Industrie sich sehr stark zurückhält. Mit Experimenten, Geld investiert, obwohl es in manchen Teilen noch ganz gut funktioniert, auch mit der medizinischen Entwicklung. Also das muss sie in stärkerem Maße noch beweisen, finde ich. Dann ist die nächste Frage das Phantom-Mars-Flug, Bermundermars-Flug. Mir ist klar, dass die Zeiträume, die genannt werden, wahrscheinlich nicht ausreichen. In zehn Jahren kann man nicht bemannt zum Mars fliegen. Ob man es in 20 oder in 30 Jahren kann, wird sich zeigen.
Warum kann man es nicht in zehn Jahren?
Es ist doch allerhand nicht nur zu bedenken, sondern auch allerhand zu basteln und zu testen. So ist die medizinische Strecke, da gibt es jetzt dieses Programm Mars 500. Das ist durchaus eine ernsthafte Geschichte, ob eine Besatzung, wenn sie einmal unterwegs ist, dann auch noch steht oder ob es dann ernsthafte Probleme gibt. Das ist der Sinn der Sache. Ich denke auch, das wird mal eines Tages gemacht werden. Alles, was der Mensch machen kann, wird er auch mal machen. Dadurch wird er sich nicht rechnen. Und der Mars ist auch nach den technischen, sage ich mal, Parametern, die er bringt, nicht besonders empfangsfreundlich.
Der Teppich ist nicht ausgerollt.
Der Teppich ist nicht ausgerollt, nicht mit hundert und siebzig Grad Minus. Vielleicht auch ein bisschen Plus, aber das ist noch gar nicht ganz sicher, ob das wirklich auch Plus Temperaturen sind. Da gibt es unterschiedliche Theorien. Also zum Mars zu fliegen, ist nicht das Gleiche wie auf den Mond zu fliegen. Obwohl es Leute geben würden, die sich sagen, ich bin sofort dabei.
Aber trotzdem drückt sich ja in der Raumfahrt mehr als, glaube ich, in irgendeiner anderen technischen Disziplin auch so ein Wunsch der Menschheit an sich aus, über die eigenen Grenzen hinauszugehen. Und es ist da in den Errungenschaften, die man in der Raumfahrt bisher realisiert hat, auch seine eigene Erfüllung zu finden. Wenn ich zurückdenke, was der Start des Sputniks und was die erste Mondlandung, überhaupt auch natürlich die erste Umrundung, all diese Meilensteine, die erreicht wurden, in den Köpfen immer wieder bewirkt hat, es ist ja vielleicht, lässt sich das so ohne Weiteres technisch nicht erklären, aber offensichtlich ist es einfach eine emotionale Dimension, die man dann auch in Geld gar nicht mehr ausdrücken kann.
Das sehe ich genauso, wie Sie sagen. Der Mensch wird das, was er irgendwie erreichen kann, angehen, was im Bereich dessen ist, was die Wissenschaft, die Technik gestattet. Es gibt natürlich auch eine philosophische Komponente. Tsiolkovsky, der Vater der Raumfahrt, wie ihn die Russen nennen bei sich, hat zum Beispiel gesagt, die Erde ist die Wiege der Menschheit, aber man kann nicht immer in der Wiege bleiben. Das kann man als Heiligtum verbreiten. Man kann aber auch sagen, na ja, hat er eben gesagt. Dann gibt es die Frage, geht man in den Weltraum nun als Roboter, wie das die Science-Fiction-Filme, die amerikanischen vor allen Dingen, mit Waffen und mit Mord und Totschlag, ist das die Mission der Menschheit? Oder lässt man diese Waffen zu Hause? Momentan sieht es nicht so aus, dass man diese zu Hause lassen will. Also da ist da schon Philosophie dabei. Dann ist die Frage, gibt es einen bemannten Planeten irgendwo, wo wir umsiedeln könnten? Da frage ich mich, warum sollten wir dann umsiedeln? Sind wir denn wie die Wildschweine, die die Erde kaputt, also auch in der Perspektive, so sehen, es wird alles mal kaputt sein oder zu Ende sein. Die Ressourcen werden wir vernichtet haben. Oder wir werden also zu viel sein auf dieser Erde. Die Wildschweine, die Graben, die, deshalb sage ich das, die Mahlbäume, die Kastanien um, und dann gehen sie ein. Graben sich ihre eigene Lebensgrundlage. Das machen die Elefanten auch. Aber der Mensch ist nun mal das denkende Wesen und das sollte das humanistische Wesen sein. Also müsste man doch sagen, irgendwie ist das Bevölkerungswachstum begrenzt.
Irgendwann ist Schluss.
Irgendwann ist Schluss. Müsste man doch darauf hinarbeiten, Chinesen machen, dass das nun der richtige Weg ist mit dieser Einkind-Geschichte. Aber es muss ja irgendwo mal die Überlegung geben, eine gemeinschaftliche Überlegung dieser Menschheit. Gibt es aber nicht. Es gibt ja immer nur das Gegeneinander. Also sind wir gar noch nicht reif dazu, zu solchen Überlegungen. Und wenn es schon einen Planeten, nochmal darauf zurückzukommen, einen Planeten irgendwo gäbe, wo ähnliche Bedingungen sind wie auf der Erde, da sind ja ganz eng begrenzt diese Bedingungen, die uns lebensfähig machen, ohne Skafander und ohne irgendwelche Räume, die dann nicht verlassen werden können. Du hast ja alles künstlich. Wenn es eigentlich solchen Planeten gäbe, dann ist er weiter weg auf jeden Fall, wie 4,5 Lichtjahre. 4,2 Lichtjahre ist ja auch schon ganz viel. Das ist nicht um die Ecke.
Das ist sehr unrealistisch, dass man da jemals...
Das ist, sag ich, unrealistisch, nicht? Aber weiß man zwar es in 2.000 Jahren, in 3.000 Jahren, wir sind ja nun bloß 4 Millionen auf der Erde.
Aber ich verstehe das jetzt eher als Appell an die Menschen, sich der Verletzlichkeit des Planeten bewusster zu werden.
Eben, aber die gegenwärtige Gesellschaft ist eben so, mehr Verbrauchen ist gut. Dann flirrt die Wirtschaft. Und ich muss ehrlich sagen, ich eilige mich, wenn meine Frau zwei Scheiben Wurst anbringt in diesen Plastetiden, wo überall RTL verweilert wurde. Ich sag, geh doch lieber zum Fleischer und kauf, lass dir was abschneiden. Das ist aber dann teurer. Also wir vernichten bewusst Dinge nur, damit......und ein bisschen kurzfristig was spart, aber langfristig den Schaden hat. Ja, oder damit Gewinn gemacht wird. Irgendwer macht immer von irgendwo Gewinn. Aber wie teuer Erdöl wirklich ist in der Erde, wo die Sonne Milliarden Jahre dazu gebraucht hat, um das zu produzieren, da fragt kein Mensch danach. Es ist noch da.
Die Berechnungsgrundlage ist eigentlich, dessen, was teuer ist, ist eigentlich die falsche.
Ja.
Und das wird einem bewusster, wenn man von außen auf den Planeten schaut.
Wahrscheinlich schon. Weil man ihn auch leidensieht in gewissem Maße schon.
Ja, würde sagen, das ist genau der richtige Zeitpunkt, das interessante Gespräch dann auch langsam zum Ende zu bringen. Es gibt so viele Dinge, auf die man eigentlich eingehen könnte und die des Hinterfragens wert sind. Trotzdem vielen Dank für die Einblicke. 50 Jahre kreisen also die Menschen jetzt schon um diesen Planeten. Eigentlich eine kurze Zeit, wenn man sich so auch die technologische Entwicklung anschaut. Eigentlich ist noch nicht wirklich viel Zeit vergangen. Trotz alledem hat es in dieser kurzen Zeit eine Menge Auswirkungen gehabt. Wirkungen in technischer, wissenschaftlicher Hinsicht. Aber wie wir ja auch gemerkt haben, auch in philosophischer Hinsicht. Meiner Meinung nach trägt das schon dazu bei, auch das Selbstverständnis des Menschen neu zu prägen, auch wenn sich das noch nicht unbedingt bei jedem rumgesprochen hat.
Das sehe ich genauso. In dem Sinne bedanke ich mich auch bei Ihnen.
Ja, vielen Dank Sigmund Jähn und vielen Dank auch fürs Zuhören auch bei dieser spannenden Ausgabe hier bei Raumzeit. Es wird weitergehen und bis bald.